most of your problems could be solved
where do I get an Islamic woman you must
become a Muslim yourself first my friend
and and being a Muslim is not easy
there's a lot to learn it's a long
journey even I'm not a scholar I'm
learning you know most of the problems
you're facing currently with women can
be solved by Islam
really
hope you guys will inshallah welcome
back through this channel in the Dunya
the three Muslims upon brother Andrew
take something Islam
give it maybe a week later I think he's
already giving dawa
and I'm very excited yeah he's already
giving down let's just jump into it
we'll watch this inshallah you know if
you got yourself a nice Islamic wife she
wouldn't cheat on you she'd cook for you
she'd look after you she wouldn't have
an only fans you know most of the
problems you're facing currently with
women can be solved by Islam
really
I just told you why wait they actually
don't cheat
she'd have decency she'd cover up she'd
be God-fearing if she her family would
also keep an eye on her so her family
would tell her to obey her husband she'd
want your children she'd look after you
Islamic women are the best they
understand that the best way to serve
God is to also serve their husbands
where do I get one at well most of your
problems could be solved where do I get
an Islamic woman you must become a
Muslim yourself first my friend
and and being a Muslim is not easy
there's a lot to learn it's a long
journey even I'm not a scholar I'm
learning there's a lot to learn about
how it works and the true word of God
and the Quran and learning Arabic Etc is
not easy but if you come to Dubai you
can begin the journey and you can talk
to the same people I've talked to and
then Halas you get yourself an Islamic
life and before you know it you get to
live in peace and happiness without
worrying about her getting plowed on an
only fence account but you have to
understand that the worldly Goods the
worldly things that people find
interesting I'm totally and utterly
Beyond I don't care about money I have
too much of it I don't need Fame I have
enough of that I don't want hoes I don't
want sex with random women I don't want
clubs I don't want restaurants all of
that is boring to me the only thing that
I find interesting is genuinely trying
to save Humanity by combating The Matrix
and opening up Minds to be freed and
worshiping God and God blessing me and
favoring me and trying to become the
best version of myself all that [ __ ] is
not interesting to me so everything in
Miami is just it's it's repulsive
there's nothing in Miami for me does
that make sense if you went to Miami and
you didn't want slots didn't want drugs
and didn't want to go to restaurants and
clubs why are you in Miami
there's nothing there it's just a
generous godlessness I don't like it I
hope you understand me I'll do my best
for you but I don't like it like I'm
here in Dubai it's beautiful the mosque
is close by I've got very important work
to do I'm going to go to a center of
disabled children donate hundred
thousand dollars tomorrow and look after
them I I have things to do which are
good for me and good for the world I I
don't see what I can do in Miami what I
can go to the club and be famous and
stand with rappers and some girl who
everyone's I could do that I could put
my dick in number 82 Yeehaw I win look
what I did I'm such a cool guy look I
banged this girl just because she is
fake it's it's vapious it's empty I
don't want to do any of these things
Aiden I don't want to go
you have to understand I I don't need to
do it what is the meaning of life then
bro like what what what are we here for
once you realize that Hedonism is a
black hole and that you can pour endless
attempts at filling it you can endless
girls there's always a new one to make
endless money there's always new money
to make Hedonism is a black hole and if
you're going to live that way you're
never going to feel satisfied you have
to genuinely decipher be perspicacious
enough to look around you and work out
what you think the world needs and then
try your very best to fulfill God's will
to make the world a better place you
know what makes me happy I'll tell you
I love I walk down the street and I'll
I'll see a construction worker here in
Dubai who's working for 300 a month and
I'll just hand him a couple thousand
Dirhams at random I like walking into
the Starbucks and just paying for
everyone's dream just putting down for
500 a day I'm gonna get your coffee I
like I like I like rescuing the dogs in
Romania I have a charity that rescues
dogs in Romania I like I like doing
things that make me feel good inside
because I know it pleases God I I will
not if I go to the club in Miami
yeah yeah yeah everyone's everyone says
I'm tough to you I get some girl she's
really hot okay fine
but what unless we make a family one day
there was no point in any of it it's
just degenerate and to make a family
with a girlfriend to make a family with
a girl from Miami is hard because they
don't know how to be mothers anymore
they don't know how to be a good soft
mother and look after the child and look
after their man because they're broken
people who's the best why would I do
that I don't want to use that where do
you find a good mother
well a good mother needs to be a woman
who understands that her feminine
imperative and her duty is to be a
mother that's her duty to femininity as
a whole is the most important and
beautiful thing a woman can do is be a
mother but a girl who reluctantly
becomes a mother or thinks that her
career or going to the club or hanging
out with her friends is just as
important as being a mother is never
going to be good at it you're only good
at the things you respect
damn
uh baby come to Dubai in the sky man
like that was like an advertisement a
little bit for Dubai and all this thing
but another bless him bro like he's
definitely starting to
he's starting well that's beautiful to
see yeah yes it's it's amazing it's fun
along this is what like week one week
two or something imagine like you know
six months from now a year from now
Insha'Allah it's very nice to see
alhamdulillah and a lot of people were I
don't want to say a lot but there were
people all right enough to make it seem
like a lot that we're worried that you
know when he comes to Islam what how
he's actually going to be and I think
this is actually the best outcome this
is actually the best outcome because
he's really like internalizing the
Hadith convey from me even if it's just
one Ayah he knows he doesn't know a lot
he's admitting that may Allah bless him
and the little bit that he knows he
knows and he knows how to communicate he
has good skills in communication
storytelling and and getting his message
across he's utilizing the the little bit
he just learned about Islam in the week
he's been a Muslim and his skills that
he's built his whole life and he's
conveying the mustard of Islam very
beautifully as well and he's bro this
guy he's very smart it's something my
teacher talks about a lot which is going
to the pain points of people and the
problems people have he didn't and a lot
of people go to someone like Aiden and
be like this is proof God exists A and B
therefore C and God exists boom you know
become Muslim
but he didn't do that he's like listen
you have these problems in life you have
these struggles in life you're you feel
like life is suffocating you because of
women because of all these struggles
that you have Islam fixes all of that
Islam fixes all of that become a Muslim
do what God tells you to and join good
forbid evil and work to accomplish the
will of Allah
and everything else will be good
inshallah that's your purpose that's
what you have to focus on
man
and this I bet you there are certain
people
that probably saw him come to this land
and they probably thought to themselves
like I wonder how genuine he's being
considering that he was quote unquote
Christian but he was only Christian
because
he had like the people in the church had
power and all that stuff yeah but it's
like again I hope people see this and
they can start to like put those doubts
aside and remember you know like
remember that we're not supposed to have
doubts
about our brothers and sisters in Islam
because that's that's very close to um
was it
uh disbelief not this belief what was it
it was very close to something man I'm
not remembering 100 but
yeah I think it's just a good reminder
bro it's a good reminder that like we
need to if someone says hey I'm Muslim
like look
okay take it at face value you can look
at the actions because the actions
reveals like what's truly in their heart
but at the end of the day like only or
not only Allah knows what's in someone's
heart you know absolutely that's a
beautiful point and um I mean for anyone
who is looking at him and questioning it
because when he was a Christian it was
for like worldly reasons whatever
how do you know it's for all the reasons
he said it he said it himself all right
so he's a pretty open guy so if he now
is giving you a reason that Islam solves
these problems and Islam is the only
religion that is firm on
um you know what they actually believe
in practice and they have proper
traditional views and values then holla
so that is his answer that is why he's a
Muslim so why would you assume anything
else if he was a Muslim because you know
uh there is a Muslim superpower in the
world and I'm sure he'd admit that just
like he did when he was Christian right
so there's not much left to really
investigate to be completely honest
especially when you see a video like
this it becomes I think abundantly clear
okay 100 man May a lot guide him even
more so may Allah
and uh it's allow them to continue what
he's doing here Allah let me just let I
mean but let me just say what he said
that is like his new focal point where
he's just trying to like wake people up
to this whole like Matrix thing and like
allow them to have a free mind to like
do things in this world like let me just
say that I respect that and I seem like
this actually I think one or two videos
where he was talking about the Matrix
and you know I know we see like major
Junior and we want to see the Dunya
instead of the Matrix but he put in a
way where I was just like oh wow I never
really thought about it like that and
he's he's big bro he's not big he's he's
been making me see things differently
bro as I'm like traveling here as I'm
like just going about these day-to-day
things I'm just like reflecting and I'm
like
damn like I I have I've never really
thought of it like this bro
yeah 100 and that's a whole other topic
bro the depth to that whole topic is uh
is it goes down deep man so inshallah
maybe we'll make a whole episode one day
about it inshallah hope that we can have
him on the podcast one day to talk about
it with us it'd be nice
foreign